[Music]
in excuses excuses news excuses never
prosper
alright submit it by foot for you wanted
something fun right now you're a mind
reader so it is actually possible to be
allergic to exercise I've been trying to
tell people all right well [ __ ]
unhealthy person wrote this [ __ ]
article David David
really you could be in it allergic well
there are people that like allergic to
water allergic to the Sun allergic to
wife yeah
alerts the Wi-Fi yeah this person got
crazy migraines there anytime there was
like Wi-Fi or life is everywhere you go
now
cuz that radiofrequency that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah but in anyway this thing it's
called I lost my place it's called
exercise induced anaphylaxis what that
what happened do they start sneezing
itchy eyes they see [ __ ] dumbbells
and they start [ __ ] getting a rash
this one example of this man his name is
Joe he went to dinner he chosen the oh
yeah it can't be the only one sorry
kill them all alright yeah so he went to
eat with his parents he ate a pizza and
then after he ate a pizza with his mom
he went to the gym got the pizza yes on
the elliptical and then about a half
hour into the workout he said that he
started feeling weird because I've got
water II was having trouble breathing
and then in another five minutes and
it's not from working out right after
eating the greasiest food in the world
so right no so then you saying that he
was struggling to breathe even more how
much anyway because that could be a
contributing factor not true I don't
know
a teepee worked out afterwards it throw
up yeah well the thing is his eyes were
swollen and like he couldn't breathe and
like he was having an allergic reaction
like you physically saw like you could
see his eyes when he turned around he
looked at the mirror in his eyes were
stolen every part of his face was
falling okay
his first thing was it's the exercise
not he was rushed to the ER oh yeah I
mean he was pumped up with a whole bunch
of steroids and antihistamines and then
they later diagnosed him saying that he
had an allergic reaction to the exercise
the combination of the exercise so it
was food-related
the combo what is the the thing that
caused the allergic reaction or what was
the thing that his body couldn't handle
like pizza and cardiovascular yeah so
they're saying that it's really hard to
pinpoint what exactly causes this yeah
because when you work out and like
you're exercising your blood palm so
like one theory is that as your blood is
pumping through your body it's sending
like different cells to different parts
of the body and then they react
differently or like your stomach like
whatever bacteria you having your gut
might react a certain way with the
combination of exercising so it's really
hard to really narrow down so he's
allergic to himself pretty much Wow
so maybe it's just the cardio aspect of
it we're like his maybe he could do like
weight training that you know leaves the
heartrate like not as like [ __ ]
intense as cardio so this is a common
enough for it to have its own word yeah
allergic to exercise did he try like
okay let me not eat pizza before I
exercise yeah well yeah they're saying
that it's really hard to that's the
first step you like what affects certain
people because everyone's different so
they're just saying like it could be
like this one particular food that gives
you that reaction when you that makes
sense any food yeah or maybe there was a
topping on the pizza that he was
allergic to that he did you know and
to do an exercise we heard that actually
from someone that I know he remember who
it was but then they were saying who
told me I don't know if one of you guys
so if this sounds familiar me no but
someone told me that when they eat
seafood and then their heart rate goes
up so whether that's like exercising or
like playing or on or doing whatever
then they start breaking out and like
rashes they have the yeah baby but it
was like specific sleep they eat seafood
and not work out they don't break out
yeah yeah like if their heart rate stays
at a certain like BPM I so that's what
it's kind of like how you know if you
take Thailand on any other drug you say
don't drink right because when you drink
I think the flushing of the circulation
kind of intensifies the effects of the
drug that you're taking so I'm thinking
the exercise is kind of the alcohol in
this situation and it's probably not the
exercise alone is probably something in
the pizza and like the seafood are being
initiation and then after they took it
and then the exercise just this
increased circulation intensified it
yeah that's nothing so what you're
saying is no more pre-workout he could
probably not give me energy
cause he could probably have pizza and
then have sex and the same thing will
happen yeah well yeah I did write this
interesting observation here they're
saying that almost all types of exercise
like running dancing biking have been
reported to cause all this reaction but
except there haven't been any reports of
anyone having a reaction after swimming
so swimming is the one exception it
seems like that's funny because they
tell you that old myth is like you have
to wait before you go swimming
maybe that's why maybe people actually
wait oh yeah they digest it what they
say don't get in the pool yet you know
are you conscious of that of what like
he's working out no no
you don't get in the water no I don't
think so because nowadays if I get in
the water I don't swim whatever that's
true it's salmon hotdogs in the pool
whatever but you could if you never do
anything I try to I was young once and
it was it grossed me out in the water
yeah in the water because I was wet no
no and your chlorine water was getting
into the pizza that's nasty I thought
you meant let me like my head would be
dry with the pizza but you would smell
the chlorine now I know yeah it's just
like it just doesn't go together
I don't smell the chlorine yeah what
kind of pool have you guys good
you shouldn't smell the chlorine in the
pool you don't you there's levels too
much chlorine though yeah your eyes are
[ __ ] party but like I'm [ __ ] here
to have [ __ ] yeah yeah but you
guys are still working out right yes
keep up with that is that I really have
that I don't really like to take a
precaution to eating and then working
out like I just deal with the if I eat
and I work out after if I end up
throwing up in my mouth a [ __ ] yeah I
can't be like super greasy foods before
I work out like I just I just get tired
like if I ate a pizza I'm like the first
thing is not let's go run I'm like let
me take a nap yeah well I just want more
dessert or you know junk leads to more
junk you know when I eat like a big-ass
[ __ ] greasy burrito
I think I'm resting for the next two
hours like I can't work out immediately
I don't get sick though I just feel
tired
I like sluggish yeah I just feel like
that's too much the weight like the
weight goes like a hundred pounds more
like this is my regular weight but when
I eat a burrito now my regular weight
turns into like 200 pounds and it's good
too because it style of
we'd so we power lift and then before I
got pretty I would wear a belt you know
for more support and then if you're full
and the belts already supposed to fit
snug and then you tighten it and then
though you feel like you're about to
throw up because the food's getting
close your stomach's getting pushed
that's scary I don't mean like that I
try not to
yeah I really try it but sometimes like
it's like we have people come from out
of town and we scheduled all [ __ ] up
and we eat and then that kind of
trickled into training then you're like
I still got you there's a new trip where
people are like drinking before they
train I don't know why I think like beer
like taking shots of whiskey
I have no idea but their muscles more
yeah and they're like [ __ ] it they go
hand I said people i barbell with
full-on like chicken bones and [ __ ] yeah
I see that's it I see them like doing
weights they go off to the side take a
couple bites I'm sitting there and I'm
like damn that teriyaki chicken smells
so good that's exaggerated I feel like I
don't know why yeah or like you know
you're just like me Raymond no no yeah I
can wait like that's just being
exaggerated some people they make
Guanabara like a whole day activity like
it's Disneyland so to them it's like
squatting is a ride so they get on the
ride and they go I meet some charros
another ride the Colonel's oh yeah
little oh your doughnuts at the front
sometimes yeah so you see dudes like
lifting taking a bite of their doughnut
I was like how do you do that [ __ ] and
then I would show up to go train on an
empty stomach
I'm so weak empty stuff I kind of like
empty stomach sometimes because it it my
adrenaline kicks in faster because I'm
so hungry that that hunger you know when
you have you ever had like that hunger
rage that hangry and I use that as
motivation but then yeah it sometimes
works really well but sometimes I get
tired are you guys anything
most scented topical things like love
body wash what did you break out yeah uh
yeah I thought you were cool oh and
stuff is that okay yeah I mean
it's like lotions mostly lotions body
wash anything that goes on your lips
that's not Vaseline it gets me right
even here from even from kissing or any
type of like lip balm like Carmack's -
it breaks me that hell out and I kissed
this girl once and immediately after
that we're never winner she's like
nothing I was like you sure she's like
you just car makes it like they don't
Swale but I get like a little like heat
rash type thing wait what are you
wearing no I think before I kiss a grab
do this does that you - I don't know
because I don't kiss girls who have
lipstick on cuz it messes up it's like a
window light it's all right here hold it
hey guys thanks for watching the last
episode did you love it I know you did
but guess what you can also follow us on
our personal social media accounts with
the links in the description box below
so both follow all of us now to watch
more videos check them out up there
[Music]